>> I WANT TO ASK ABOUT OMAR. I
THINK THAT'S UNFAIR TO HER.
>> YOU PUBLICISTS?
>> WHAT?
>> I'M JUST SOMEONE WHO CARES
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THERE'S
SOMEONE OUT THERE WHO IS IN THE
MINORITY WHO HAS PRESS AGAINST
HER AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
ALL USE THE SAME LANGUAGE AND
ASK EVERYBODY ELSE TO BE
CAREFUL.
>> THAT'S A COMEDIAN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> STORMY, STORMY, IF THAT'S
YOUR COMPETITION, YOU HAVE
NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
COMEDIAN, IT'S THE ONLY TRUMP
DIDN'T MAKE GREAT AGAIN, INSTEAD
LITTLE HALL MONITORS WITH TINNY
WRISTS, STORMY, THOUGH, NOW SAYS
TRUMP, THAT'S A BAD LAWYER, ONE
THAT FACES CENTURIES IN JAIL, SO
NOW STORMY IS DOING STAND-UP TO
EARN A PAYCHECK BUT AT LEAST
SHE'S STANDING UP TRYING TO EARN
A MY CHECK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THANK YOU.
IN OTHER NEWS, THE NEW YORK
TIMES HAD A BIG, TRUMP LOST A
BUNKED UNTIL THE 90's, I KNOW
IT'S AMAZING.
THE MOVIE HOME ALONE, HOW ABOUT
THAT VANILLA ICE GUY, MARK MY
WORDS, THAT FELLOW IS GOING
PLACES, WHEN YOU CAN'T FIND ANY
NEWS TO MATCH YOUR DELUSIONS,
YOU WILL MAKE ANYTHING ELSE NEWS
INCLUDING WHAT TRUMP TALKS ABOUT
15 YEARS AGO.
>> ABOUT 15 YEARS AGO I WAS
SERIOUSLY IN DEBT, I WAS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DEBT BUT
I FOUGHT BACK AND I WON BIGLY.
>> WHAT OTHER BOMBSHELLS WOULD
THEY GLEAN FROM REALITY, ONE OF
THE REAL HOUSEWIVES THROUGH A
GLASS OF MERLOT TO ANOTHER HOUSE
WIVES.
IS IT JOURNALISM WHEN SOMEONE
ELSE GIVES YOU SOMEONE ELSE'S
TAX RETURNS.
BUT UNDER TRUMP REAL NEWS IS FIT
FOR THE OLD NEWS BECAUSE WHEN
THE REAL NEWS IS GOOD, THE MEDIA
HAS TO FIND CONFLICT TO MAKE
THEIR PRESIDENT BEARABLE.
IF ONLY THERE WERE A DRUG.
>> HOW WAS THAT NEWS?
I'M SO TIRED OF "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" PACKAGING OLD NEWS LIKE
IT'S OLD NEWS.
WHAT WILL YOU TELL ME NEXT, THE
WALL CAME UP.
THE MEDIA THINKS WE ARE IDIOTS.
>> YOU SHOULD TALK TO YOUR
DOCTOR, MAYBE SOMETHING FROM
COMMON SENSE.
COMMON SENSE NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT IT IS.
A MEDIA TO REPACKAGE OLD BAR
DAMAGE, TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> THIS IS FROM 1990.
ISN'T THERE A WAY TO MAKE IT NEW
AND FRESH AGAIN.
>> DECADES' OLD MONDAY NEWS ITEM
OR MODERN-DAY STANDOFF BY
ERASING ALL OF YOUR LONG-TERM
MEMORY.
YOU'LL BE BLOWN AWAY EVEN BY THE
MOST REPORTING.
>> HOW DO I DO THAT?
>> BY ERASING YOUR LONG-TERM
MEMORY.
WHO ARE YOU ANYWAY?
ANNOUNCER, HAVE BEEN DOING THE
SAME THING FOR 3 YEARS.
>> REALLY?
>> YES.
THIS STUFF REALLY WORKS.
>> WOW.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
DID YOU KNOW TRUMP HAS BEEN
MARRIED 3 TIMES.
HE LOST TO GOLF.
HE'S NEVER GOING TO BE ELECTED.
>> HE WAS ELECTED IN 2016.
I MUST HAVE MISSED THAT.
LOOK AT THIS, THE WHOLE CITY IS
GETTING INDOOR PLUMBING, WHERE
IS THE WATER GOING TO COME FROM.
WOMEN TO GET THE RIGHT TO VOTE,
I DON'T LIKE THAT AT ALL.
>> YOU'RE AN IDIOT, I'M LEAVING
YOU.
>> WHO ARE YOU?
>> I'M YOUR WIFE.
SOMEONE MARRIED ME.
THAT'S AWESOME.
THANKS PRODUCT'S WHOSE NAME I
FORGET.
>> MAKING EVERYTHING OLD BRAND
NEW AGAIN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THE POINT IS THE MEDIA IS
DRENCHED IN OWN FAILURE HAS TO
REAANYMORE NATE --
>> PEOPLE TRANSITION OF POWER.
>> WOULDN'T LEAVE FOLLOWING BAD
STUFF REVEALED, A CRISIS,
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> I AGREE WITH CONGRESSMAN
NADLER THAT WE ARE IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS?
>> WE ARE.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS LOOKS
LIKE, WELL, OPEN YOUR EYES.
>> LOOKS LIKE DON LEMON, WHAT IS
THE CRISIS, THAT THEY ARE OUT OF
IDEAS, DO YOU THINK IT BOTHERS
TRUMP?
HE HAS OTHER CONCERNS THAT.
>> THAT RUNWAY IS LIKE A SKATING
RINK.
I THINK IT WAS PUT IN BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
WHO KNOWS?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> IT DOES FEEL LIKE A TRAP.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHOEVER GOT THAT
THING, THAT'S A TRAP.
I'M TELLING YOU, IT'S LIKE --
IT'S LIKE RIDICULOUS.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE IF HE WENT
DOWN?
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE IF I WENT
DOWN THE PRESS WOULD HAVE A
FIELD DAY?
>> IT'S LIKE FLOATING AROUND A
PIECE OF ICE.
>> AS I STAND HERE FLOATING
AROUND ON A PIECE OF ICE.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT
LEAPING TO PODIUM, YOU HAVE NO
IDEA BUT I'M GOING THROUGH WITH
IT.
IT'S THE WORST DAMN STAGE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I WONDER WHO DID THIS ONE?
>> STUPID PEOPLE DID THIS ONE.
NO, NO.
THEY MAY BE THE ENEMY.
>> SO WHAT KIND OF PRESIDENT
TALKS ABOUT THE SLIPPERY STAGE?
THAT GUYS THE COMPLETE OPPOSITES
OF A POLITICIAN, THERE'S NO
PLATITUDE, JUST HIS THOUGHT ON
SLIPPERY FLOORS.
SO NOW THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
ACCUSE TRUMP OF THE VERY WORST,
WHAT'S THE NEXT STOP ON THE
CRAZY TRAIN, LET'S REVIEW, FIRST
STOP WAS TRUMP UNSTABLE, SECOND
STOP, HE'S INSANE, THE THIRD
RUSSIAN SPY WHO STOLE THE
ELECTION, THE FOURTH HE WON'T
LEAVE OFFICE, THE FIFTH HE
CREATED CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS,
WHAT'S NEXT?
COULD TRUMP BEEN AN ISIS AND
MAROON 5?
IF THE MEDIA WANTS YOU TO THINK
THERE'S UNSTABLE TYRANT
BARRICADING HIMSELF IN OVAL
OFFICE, WHO IS TRYING TO CREATE
THE CRISIS REALLY?
TO WHAT END, WHAT DO THEY WANT
TO HAPPEN, THEY ARE STILL TRYING
TO UNDO 2016 INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO WIN 2020.
IT'S THE LOSERS' RESPONSE TO
LOSING, WINNERS ADMIT THEY ARE
WRONG AND THEY CHANGE, BUT NOT
HERE, THEY JUST DIG A DEEPER
GRAVE AS THEY REELECT THE PERSON
WHO KEEPS HANDING THEM THE
SHOVELS.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WRITER, COMEDDIA -- COMEDIAN
CHRIS.
KATHERINE KEMPF.
HE FLOSSES WITH THE TRANSALANTIC
CABLE.
FORMER WWE SUPER STAR TYRUS.
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I FEEL LIKE EVERYONE, ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE TOTALLY OBSESSED
WITH JUST TAKING ON TRUMP.
THEY ARE NOT LEGISLATING, THEY
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB, THEY
ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING THAT WE
PAY THEM TO DO AND WHILE THEY
KEEP WASTING TIME DOING THAT,
LIKE YOU SAID, 2020 IS COMING
CLOSER AND CLOSER, THEY WILL
HAVE NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT AND
NOW THEY ARE LITERALLY TALKING
ABOUT CODIFYING, PUTTING INTO
FEDERAL LAW THINGS THAT HELP GET
TRUMP AFTERWARDS BECAUSE THEY
ARE NEVER GOING TO LET IT GO AND
WHILE THEY ARE MIRED IN THAT,
OUR STATE LEGISLATORS HAVE BEEN
BUSY ALSO WRITING BILLS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN GET TRUMP
AFTERWARDS AND ALL IT'S DOING IS
GOING TO AFFECT US AS CITIZENS.
>> IS CODIFYING LIKE WHEN YOU
TAKE A FISH?
[LAUGHTER]
>> LIKE -- YOU KNOW WHAT IT
MEANS.
>> FOR BAIT.
>> OH, I'M CONFUSED.
>> NOT A COD FISH.
>> PETER PAN.
>> I KNOW THAT WORD AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW MY LAST NAME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NOW EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
>> BEST FRIEND THAT KNOWS WHO HE
IS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ANYTHING INTERESTING ABOUT
THE SHOW IN GENERAL?
I JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
NAME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT I FIND INTERESTING IS
THAT THE MEDIA STILL USES THE
WORD SHOCKING IN STORMY DANIELS
STORY AND I DON'T LIKE IT,
NUMBER ONE, MOST THINGS LIKE IF
YOU GET A POP-UP, STORMY DANIELS
WITH FACE, CHANCES ARE WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT GIVES YOU A
VIRUS OF SOME KIND AND I CAN'T
CLICK ON THAT.
I DON'T LIKE THAT, NUMBER 1,
NUMBER 2, NOT SHOCKING, NOT
SHOCKING THAT TRUMP SLEPT WITH
HER.
THE WHOLE THING WAS NEVER
SHOCKING.
>> A BILLIONAIRE IN NEW YORK
CITY, I THINK THAT'S REQUIRED,
KAT.
NOT A QUESTION REALLY?
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU
WANT ME TO GO WITH THAT.
>> ARE YOU HAPPY SHE'S DOING
STAND-UP?
>> I FEEL LIKE IT'S FINE.
>> I COIN THAT PHRASE.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S BETTER THAN
DOING PORN TO DO STAND-UP, MORE
DIFFICULT, SO BEST OF LUCK TO
HER.
THERE'S NOTHING WORST THAN BEING
ON STAGE AND TRYING TO TELL
JOKES AND HAVING NOBODY LAUGH,
IT'S REALLY, REALLY QUITE SAD,
BUT YOU KNOW, I WISH HER THE
BEST, I WISH HER THE BEST, I
REALLY, REALLY DO AND IT'S FUNNY
THAT HER LAWYER AVENATTI,
OBVIOUSLY HE'S WORST THAN TRUMP.
WHAT ARE THEY EVEN TALKING
ABOUT?
HE STOLE MONEY FROM PEOPLE?
>> YES.
>> TRUMP LOST 2 BILLION -- I
LOST MY CAT IN MY APARTMENT
ONCE, SOMETIMES YOU LOSE STUFF.
BUT ALL THAT MATTERS IS THAT YOU
COME OUT ON TOP, YOU KNOW, I
FOUND THE CAT.
HE HAS A CAREER.
ALL IS AS WELL AND ENDS WELL,
OVER AND OUT.
>> TYRUS LAST WORD TO YOU.
>> I WANT TO SAY ABOUT DOING
STAND-UP, I'M NORMALLY IN
TROUBLE.
IT'S NOT WORKING, THEY HAVE A
PARTICULAR PERSON FOR THE JOB --
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> COMEDY IS TOUGH.
MAYBE THE AUDIENCE NEED TO HELP
ME, THE WORD CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS, THEY SAY IT A LOT BUT NO
ONE ASKED HOW SO, LIKE EXPLAIN.
I WAS GOING GUEST IN SHOW, WHAT
DOES IT MEAN, WELL, OPEN YOUR
EYES, GET IT OPEN.
>> YES.
>> WHAT IS IT?
IT'S THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> EXACTLY.
>> THE CONSTITUTION STRESSED
OUT, WHAT IS -- WHAT IS THE
CRISIS, THEY USED THE TERM WITH
NO DEFINITION.
>> I HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS EVERY DAY.
>> NO, I DON'T --
[LAUGHTER]
>> NO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THE REALITY --
>> CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS, HOW
SO.
>> WHENEVER I HAVE CHEESE.
>> I'M NOT GOING -- I'M NOT
BITING ON THAT.
>> I'M LACTOSE INTOLERANT.
>> OUR FOUNDING FATHERS WOULD BE
IN SHAME.
>> THAT'S CONSTITUTIONAL WITH
ENGLAND SAYING THEY WANT IT
BACK.